one of my listeners friend of mine who
hosts a podcast himself James all
teacher wants to know the proprietary
algorithms of their of the medallion no
he's he wants to know has it become
harder for you given the rise in
quantitative hedge funds quant funds and
the thousands of PhDs trying to create
new algorithms has that made it harder
to create alpha so can you say what
alpha means in the context of hedge
funds for people that aren't familiar
and then answered that particular
question well when you say alpha first
you have to understand beta hmm and beta
is the the stock market as a whole
let's say the S&P average so you could
just invest in that and you would be a
hundred percent beta all your return
would be would come from let's say the
S&P the standard & poor's average alpha
is a source of earnings that is a THOG
'''l to that it's a toggle to that and
so that's alpha now some medallion fund
is I think ninety percent alpha of 95
percent of alpha it really doesn't
matter where the stock market is going
for the medallion fund we have another
medallion fund is only open to employees
of the company of Renaissance and me of
course as a founder and shareholder so
and and we have some publicly available
funds which you have some beta then not
a hundred percent but of course they
don't do as well as medallion but but
they do quite well till today
I'm sorry again I'm always here if you
need if you need a cup of sugar I'm here
so in that space the question is I've
heard it described that these super
computers and computers in general are
of course increasing exponentially
example of power computing power over
time and cost is coming down and yet the
super computers themselves are suffering
from the fact that there's more
subscriptions there's more people that
want to use the computer now than in the
earlier days so it's sort of offsetting
the exponential gains and processing
power and I guess James alterus question
here is has the just a net quantity of
hedge funds and quant PhD yeah I didn't
answer that question yeah so I think the
question is do we have competition and
how much competition has competition
hurt us at all because there are more
and more quantitative funds I'm to a
point I think most funds are not
quantitative funds but there's certainly
an increasing number of funds that
quantitative and our secret is just to
stay ahead of everybody
hmm I are the best possible people and
the research goes on all the time all
the time or doing research trying to
find new predictive signals effective
signals for example that's a big example
so a signal as well you know what a
signal I should tell you what a
predictive signal is a signal that tells
you what's that what's going to happen
yes some probability and stuff like with
a greater than probability greater than
half and the more these signals that you
have and independent they're not
correlated with each other they're
highly correlated it's really good one
second
the more you have the better and we have
I won't even say the number and I'm not
sure what it is but it's a very large
number of predictive circles
and they keep being developed and
sometimes these signals lose their power
yes you have to discard them how the
people have caught on or whatever in the
earliest days of my training I traded
commodities and commodities had a
tendency to trend mm-hmm a pretty strong
tendency to trend so that was a good way
to make money you would just say well it
was up last week it's likely to be up
next week or so on but people gradually
caught on to trending so after several
years maybe 10 years after I started in
the business the trending in commodities
had completely disappeared stocks never
trended particularly so there was no
real trending stocks but come on which
there was and so so that's an example of
a signal just disappeared
mm-hmm scenario so on the print board we
know we're discovering new signals other
people might find some of those as well
and that might the effect of that might
be but the signal kind of goes away push
to the people using them but so we have
awfully smart people and they keep
coming up with new signals so that's and
we've stayed
you know we've stayed with ahead